OK.
We have some friends on the right and some
friends on the left that are really missing
the mark on a story about Mitt Romney and
Colin Powell and potentially George W. Bush
not supporting Trump in the upcoming election.
So here's what's going on.
In the last 24 hours, there have been reports
and interviews that former Republican President
George W. Bush, current Republican Senator
Mitt Romney, lifelong Republican Colin Powell
and some others will not be supporting the
reelection of Donald Trump.
Now, it's important to understand that that
doesn't mean they're necessarily voting for
Joe Biden.
We'll get to that in a second.
The reactions from the right have been completely
predictable.
These are loser triggered Republicans who
are either jealous of Trump's success or mad
that Trump doesn't listen to them or they
have personal grudges.
Don Junior tweeted.
Who cares?
He argues that who gives a you know what?
That I think it's Colin Powell or Mitt Romney
isn't going to be supporting Trump.
Sort of like these are losers.
We don't care about them.
They're not even really Republicans as far
as we're concerned.
Predictable response from the right.
I don't care.
But sadly, I'm seeing some really bad takes
on this from some people on the left.
And they're mostly coming from the slice of
the left that is virulently, virulently irrationally
and high.
Joe Biden, I've started hearing from people
on the left, stuff like David.
The reason Romney and Colin Powell and maybe
Bush aren't supporting Trump is because Biden
is so far right that they are just more aligned
with Biden's politics.
They're Republicans and Biden is basically
a Republican.
That's why they are doing this and everybody
should be criticized for it.
That is absolute idiocy.
And it's time for people to pull up their
big boy pants and understand what's actually
going on here.
Come on with me.
Let's let's take a journey.
So first.
And.
Foremost, what actually happened over the
last 24, 48 hours, a couple of different things.
Number one, The New York Times reports that
former Republican President George W. Bush
is not going to support the reelection of
Trump.
This doesn't mean that he's going to vote
for Joe Biden.
And in his defense, a spokesman for Bush is
saying the report is wrong.
George W. Bush is steering clear of politics,
which, quite frankly, is a coy way of saying
he's not supporting Trump.
He may just not be getting involved whatsoever.
But that is where the George W. Bush situation
stands as of right now.
Not really a denial that George W. Bush doesn't
support Trump, but simply just saying he's
not getting involved in politics right now.
Bush's brother, Jeb Bush, the former Republican
governor for Florida, he says he's not sure
who he's going to vote for.
Mitt Romney, current Republican senator from
Utah, will not endorse Trump and was, by the
way, Mitt Romney yesterday out with protesters
in Washington, D.C., saying a black lives
matter.
Neither will late.
Senator John McCain's wife, Cindy McCain,
she will not be supporting Donald Trump.
And here's Colin Powell yesterday on CNN,
straight up telling Jake Tapper he's voting
for Joe Biden.
And so we're not a country of just a president.
We have a Congress.
We have a Supreme Court.
But most of all, we have the people of the
United States, the ones who vote, the ones
who vote him in.
And the ones who vote him out.
I couldn't vote for him in 96.
And I certainly cannot in any way support
President Trump this year.
So, yeah, I know you didn't vote for him in
2016, I assume, based on the fact that you
approved Joe Biden when senator then Senator
Obama picked him to be his running mate in
2008.
I assume you're going to be voting for Joe
Biden.
I'm very close to Joe Biden on a social matter
and on a political matter.
I've worked with him for 35, 40 years, and
he is now the candidate.
And I will be voting for him.
So the reactions from some who have been writing
to me have been war criminal.
Colin Powell is voting for Biden to war criminals.
No surprise or Republicans are voting for
Biden because Biden's basically a Republican.
This is an indictment of Joe Biden.
Now, you can dislike Joe Biden.
You can choose not to vote for Joe Biden.
But the bad takes about this are really painful,
like it's cringe worthy to watch.
You've got people on the left in the face
of Republicans abandoning their own party
for what they see as the good of the country.
And the people on the left that are writing
to me are criticizing these Republicans and
criticizing Joe Biden.
Come on, guys.
You're looking foolish.
For years we've been saying, wouldn't it be
great if some Republicans did what's right
for the country instead of just checking the
party orthodoxy?
And that's exactly what they are doing here.
The better analysis is they are so disgusted
by what Donald Trump is doing that lifelong
Republicans are saying, I can't stand with
my party.
I can't actually just go with the party orthodoxy.
I'm going to have to support someone else
who I would normally never support, never
mind publicly admitting it.
And, you know, reminder, Bush spokesman is
denying this.
Anyway, we don't know what's going on with
George Bush, but it doesn't matter.
Certainly, as far as Colin Powell goes and
Mitt Romney, this should be be viewed as a
good thing.
A Democratic candidate in the face of absolute
totalitarian Donald Trump is a reasonable
enough diplomat that lifelong Republicans
are okay saying this time around.
I can't just check the box that my party wants
me to check.
I'm not with the lunatics like Ted Cruz.
I'm not with Tom Cotton and these whack jobs.
I am going to think for myself and do what
I see is good for the country.
It should be applauded that they're doing
this now.
It's also a really bad example of post facto
rationalization by some on the left who are
now coming up with these criticisms.
If Bernie convinced some Republicans to vote
for him, it would be rightly cheered.
If Biden does it, it's because Biden is a
Republican.
Come on, guys, give me a break.
These guys are conservatives.
They're not fascists.
So they aren't going to support a president
taking the country down a very dark path.
And that's supposed to be an indictment of
Biden.
Now, of course, at the same time, it's still
true that Biden is no progressive.
Biden is a totally standard center left Democrat.
He wants a fifteen dollar minimum wage.
His health care proposal would give about
30 million people.
Additionally, health care trumps would take
it away from about 24 to 32 million.
Biden supports the Green New Deal as a framework.
His tax program is better than Trump's, et
cetera.
OK.
He's a center left Republican.
Now, meanwhile, Democrats don't need to celebrate
these endorsements if they don't want to.
Right.
Let some right wingers see that Mitt Romney
is saying no to Trump.
See that Colin Powell is saying no to Trump.
Let them evaluate what that means for how
they're going to vote.
And meanwhile, Joe Biden can just keep running
his campaign.
We're not whitewashing the records of these
Republicans.
These Republicans can be horrible people who
govern terribly and are just making one correct
decision here.
Right.
That that's all it has to be.
And quite frankly, the second that a Democrat
is elected to president.
These guys likely won't be our allies anymore.
We simply agree that Trump is such a systemic
danger that must be removed that they can't
vote for him just because there is an R next
to his name.
And that should be applauded.
That should be applauded.
Meanwhile, we'll go right back to arguing
about taxes and foreign policy and the entire
thing as soon as Donald Trump is removed than
a Democratic president takes over.
We are fighting a Proteau fascist here.
Don't miss the forest for the trees.
I'm ready for your disagreements.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
I look forward to hearing from you.
Remember to sign up for free to get the Daily
David Pakman Show audio podcast on iTunes,
Stitcher, Spotify, Pandora, Google Play, podcasts,
whatever your favorite podcasting software
is.
Get the daily audio podcast.
If you prefer that to YouTube clips as an
example, let me know your thoughts about these
Republican abandonments of Trump on Twitter,
where you can find me at CPAC, The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.